how's it going best my name's Peter -
Pat I bet you weren't expecting me in
this video I mean all of my videos how
do you know by my channel actually
you're right [ __ ] you bros are getting
the chance to vote for the next game
we're gonna play there's been a lot of
games that I stopped okay if you don't
want to hear me babble a little bit go
ahead and click one of mine in my
nostrils I'll annotate them I won't tell
you which one of them though they're
gonna have to guess if you want to do it
left all right five seconds three
seconds and we're done okay sorry I ran
out of time you have to listen to me now
all right
so basically I'm seeing a lot of
comments of you bros asking you like
what what happened to Kingdom Hearts war
that's your voice by the way you're
welcome
what happened to neo Cooney I even see
comments asking for like [ __ ] Skyrim
that I did two episodes like over a year
ago and I was like this has to stop
basically think about yourself for a
second have you finished every single
game that you have ever played you have
this argument it's not gonna work here's
an example here's an example if I if I'm
playing a game and my friend is sitting
next to me and I can I even though I'm
enjoying myself and I see my friend is
not enjoying it you know I'm obviously
gonna switch a game I'm not that big of
a douchebag as she gets as it sounds you
bros are that friend so I know maybe a
lot of people line like that and maybe
some people don't but I don't know I
added all my videos myself and it it
takes time it's not I'm not complaining
I'm just saying I really prefer to be
feel like excitement about uploading
something and working on
something instead of just been our
another one adage I don't want to like
these and stuff like that so that that's
my reason for if I stop playing a game
so if you notice I stop you know I'm
really sorry seriously I'm really sorry
please cut me some slack I don't know
what's I kiss but I want to eat that
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] hungry so that that was
all I want to talk about that now let's
go to the fun part the boding alright so
here we are at the voting finally it's
pretty done simple you basically just
click on the game that you want to play
with me pretty much if you're on a cell
phone or mobile device or whatever there
I put link in the description so you can
just click on those instead you can
click on how many you like or and how
many times you like it's not only like
the clicks that I'm gonna judge from one
also gonna judge from comments and you
know whatever input you bros basically
give me so I can choose the game that
you know we're all kind of like the
first game is 9 9 noun it's also known
as nine hours nine persons nine doors
it's a game for the the Nintendo DSi
so it might not look the most appealing
but it's also more of like a graphic
novel than in an actual game and so it's
not a mushroom to [ __ ] around and stuff
but the story is supposed to be really
really good it seemed pretty damn
interesting have a lot of plot twists
and stuff like that which I loves that
could be pretty cool I don't know the
second game is lone survivor by Jasper
Byrne Bjorn it's an indie horror game in
2d pixel style the story is heavily
inspired by Silent Hill it doesn't look
like a scariest game ever but who knows
and maybe who cares Jasper as far as I
know is an amazing composer and the
soundtrack for this game is this awesome
have you actually uses in a couple of
one of my videos the third game is Alice
madness Returns I don't know much about
this game except that you bros have been
suggesting it like frickin crazy I've
been kind of skeptic to it because it
seems to have a lot of combat and stuff
like that which I usually don't like but
hey if you you bros let me know what you
think about it and we'll see maybe it's
worth
sorry the fourth game is Okami I just
freaking love the art style of this game
I heard amazing things about it I'm just
not sure if it's something that you bros
will get into it or be interested in or
not but I would love to play and fifth
and finally is corpse party it's
originally an old RPG maker game that
got remade into the PSP it's really long
and it seemed very slow-paced otherwise
it seemed pretty damn interesting I'm
just not sure if it like gets more
intense later or if it's like this slow
all day long so so yeah that was all the
all the options that I have you can go
ahead and suggest if there's one game
that you really think would be awesome
to see me play I know you know I'll
check it out as well of course but these
are the main ones with that being said I
want to thank you both for participating
and helping me out and I'll see you in
the next game it's gonna be awesome
either way I can't I can't I don't have
a camera so I can't brofist but imagine
imagine a process on your butt